So you guys have heard about Dr Foutse Khomh
talking about how to find bugs from deep learning
programs, and I will then talk about how to figure
out what goes wrong - figure out the root causes
of the these bugs. So this says AI artificial
intelligence has been increasingly embedded
into modern software applications and systems and
the key enabler behind this is deep learning. And
you know deep learning is quite different from
traditional software engineering. In traditional
software development we programmers manually
write the program logic in source code, right,
but in deep learning the models actually learn
their own logic from the training data. And also,
in traditional software development everything is
encoded in symbolic representations, right, data
structures etc. etc. But in deep learning, things
are encoded into high-dimensional arrays and there
is a lot of calculus and linear algebra operations
over these arrays to make the inference.
This brings a lot of challenges
to debug deep learning models.
You know, in the old world, traditional software,
if we want to debug errors, we basically set a
breakpoint and we can step through each line of
code to figure out the root cause of this error.
But in deep learning, for neural
nets, how do we even set a breakpoint?
Even if sometimes we can actually peek into
the internals, you know, a specific layer or
neuron in the neural net, but what we can get
from at the runtime? The runtime values we get
from this neural net are high dimensional
arrays which are hard to interpret, right?
All right, let's actually look at one example.
Suppose you're a programmer and you actually
tried this recurrent neural network to classify
ready comments to positive or negative opinions,
and you find out the model accuracy is
pretty low, and you are wondering why,
right? So for example, this comment clearly
shares a negative opinion, but the model
misclassifies it as positive. So it's really hard
to tell exactly what happens inside the model,
right, and why this error occurs. And this
is actually why some people, you know,
actually call deep learning "alchemy", right?
People don't know exactly why something works
and why something doesn't work. Okay, it's
like a giant black box to us to programmers.
Our solution is to transform this complex and
familiar neural network back to something we
are familiar with, right, like, uh, finite state
machine, and in this way we can bring back all the
good stuff we have in the traditional programming
world, like, people can step through each state
in the finite state machine and inspect the state
value, um, in the in the finite state machine. So
based on this idea we actually build a debugging
tool called the DeepSeer. In the middle of this
interface is a visualization of the finite
state machine abstracted from an RN model,
and it provides programmers a bird's eye view of
what's already going on in the internal decision
making process of the model. As the model reads
each word in input text it will transit between
different state until it reach to the end of the
text to make it the final decision. And if you
click on state you can actually see the frequent
words and phrases associated with this state.
So in this way we convert those
uninterpretable high dimensional
arrays into a symbolic representation
that are interpretable to programmers.
And you can also dig into individual data points
in the training data, search and filter and
trace all the way back to the state diagram.
Going back to the previous misclassification
example, with dips here you can actually enter
this misclassified text into DeepSeer and DeepSeer
will immediately produce a state trace that
reflects the intermediate decisions made by the RN
model after reading each word in the input text.
Here, red means negative and blue means positive.
Similar to how you step through a program the
source code you can step through this state trace
and look at what happens after you know the model
reads each word in the input text. And we can see
that, you know, this RN model actually changes
minus several times when it's reading the input
text and in particular after, you know, it reads
this word quarters at the end of the sentence,
the model suddenly changes its mind from negative
to positive right and never change it back. So
it actually provides us some good hints for
further debugging - further investigation.
When we actually search this keyword quarters in
the training data, right, we can see that the data
is quite imbalanced - there are 28 sentences
that mention these quarters and 27 of them are
labeled as positive only one of them is labeled
as negative, so that means the model actually
learns a superficial correlation between
this world quarters and a positive opinion,
right? So this is very likely to be the
root cause of this misclassification.
To further confirm the usefulness of this
idea we actually did a user study with 28
CS students and asked them to debug two different
models - train on two different data sets using
DeepSeer versus another popular debugging -
deep learning debugging tool called Line and
we found that students using DeepSeer provided
more reasonable insights about the root causes.
And we also found more error-inducing keywords
in the input sentence compared with using Line.
So OK takeaways. You know, I think given the
opaqueness of deep learning, I think it's
quite important for us programmers to understand
what we are building and be responsible for the
model errors. And to achieve this goal we actually
need to build new debugging tools that account for
the unique characteristics of deep learning.
And to make these tools usable to the broad
population of programmers we need to transform the
internals of a deep learning model into something
that we are familiar with that are interpretable
to programmers rather than something that only
makes sense to machine learning experts and
machine learning theorists. Finally I want to give
a shout out to my collaborators at the University
of Alberta and thank you all for listening.